this video was made possible by
curiosity stream
get the curiosity stream nebula bundle
deal on sale now for 15
a year to watch our brand new nebula
original documentary at
curiositystream.com
wendover in march 2020
the cruise industry shut down
there are no qualifiers to that sentence
it's not that
certain ships from certain companies in
certain countries shut down
is that every ship from every company in
every country stopped accepting
passengers
in march 2020. that's
unprecedented never before in modern
times
has there been such a complete global
shutdown of an industry
of this size this isn't like airlines or
restaurants or movie theaters
they couldn't keep operating at a
certain level or with certain
precautions or in certain geographies
every single cruise ship shut down
the second that happened though time
started
ticking cruise lines were on the clock
with the biggest challenge they might
ever
face they had to survive as
organizations
with no revenue no passengers and little
to no government support
until it was safe and legal to sail
again
as it turns out doing nothing as a
company
is actually quite a lot of work
after ships dropped off their last loads
of passengers
thousands of people remained on board
the crew
naturally management started to wonder
what they should do with them
at first the answer was nothing you see
as the shutdown started much of the
global cruise fleet was in the caribbean
finishing up the peak season before
crossing the atlantic for the summer
mediterranean cruise season
as most caribbean cruises leave from the
us that meant that the american cdc's
march 14th no
sail order was what officially prevented
them from sailing
even if in practice most shut down
voluntarily that no sail order however
was initially slated to expire after
just 30 days
so most cruise lines decided to leave
their ships staffed and waited out
under the hope that they could salvage
their summer seasons on april 9th
though the cdc extended the order for
100 days
until july 24th making it very clear
that this would not
be a short-term stoppage in most cases
cruise lines are subject to the laws of
the countries in which they're
registered
which means that most cruise lines
register their vessels in countries with
loose labor laws
like panama the bahamas or malta that
typically lets them
hire from anywhere which in practice
gives them access to
low-wage labor pools from places like
eastern europe or the philippines
now cruise ships are of course massive
and correspondently need
a massive number of staff to run the
carnival panorama for example
has a crew size of 1450 people
and carnival its owner has some 23
ships that meant that once they decided
to officially pull the plug in april
they had some 26 000 staff members from
all around the world
who each needed to get home in the era
of paired back flight schedules
border closures and complex testing and
quarantine protocols
it soon became very clear that finding
26 000 flight itineraries for 26 000
stranded crew members
would not be a quick and simple exercise
so rather than 26 000 itineraries
they cut it back to just about seven
in late april 18 of carnival's 23 ships
started sailing to a spot off the coast
of grand bahama island
then once together over a few days in
early may
some 10 000 crew members shuffled
between the various ships using tenders
the task entailed more or less grouping
the crew into geographic regions
southeast asian crew boarded the
carnival conquest south asian crew
boarded the ecstasy eastern european
crew boarded the magic
and so on and so forth once the crew
transfer was completed
on may 4th seven ships the liberty dream
magic breeze ecstasy conquest and glory
left the carnival glory had the shortest
journey of the mall
tasked with repatriating many of the
caribbean crew members to their homes
just five days after departing it docked
in saint lucia then the next day in
saint vincent and the grenadines
then saint george's barbados and so on
and so forth
completing a multi-week milk run of the
west indies
next to complete its mission was the
carnival breeze dropping british crew
off in southampton
while the carnival magic made a quick
stop in gibraltar before arriving in
dubrovnik croatia
to repatriate much of carnival's eastern
european crew
meanwhile the journeys of the liberty
dream conquest and ecstasy
were just getting started as they each
stopped at various south african ports
to restock
refuel and drop off african crew members
after two weeks of sailing the indian
ocean
the dream and conquest arrived in the
waters off the coast of denpasar
to bring many of the indonesian crew
home while the liberty arrived in mumbai
india
the dream then made a quick journey west
to jakarta to drop off more of its
indonesian crew
just as the ecstasy made it to mumbai as
well carrying
even more indian crew members then as
soon as the conquest met the dream in
jakarta
the two sailed together to manila to
drop off a huge number of philippine
staff members
while the liberty and ecstasy sailed
south to anchor off the coast of colombo
and drop off sri lankan crew with that
as june turned into july
this repatriation mission was complete
with some crew having spent two
months sailing from the bahamas to get
back
home while getting these 26 000 crew
members
off their boats and off their payroll
was a major concern of management at
carnival once the long-term nature of
the shutdown became clear
attention among all cruise line
management teams quickly refocused onto
how to actually survive
as a business when there's no business
to be made
in the third quarter of 2019 each of the
three largest cruise companies earned
billions in revenue
in the same quarter one year later
carnival earned 31 million dollars in
revenue
norwegian 6.5 million and royal
caribbean managed to earn
negative 33 million dollars in revenue
something almost unheard of among large
companies
so how do you survive as a company when
you quite literally
have no way to make money
well cruise lines did have one thing
going for them prior to covid they were
highly highly profitable in fact
many often pocketed hundreds of dollars
in profit
per passenger in addition cruising is a
highly cyclical industry what that means
is that
when the overall economy is good the
cruise business is quite good
while when the overall economy is bad
the cruise business
is quite bad that's because when money
gets tight for a person
one of the first things to go is
vacation
therefore cruise lines are used to
weathering out leaner times
so they traditionally keep quite a lot
of money in their war chests
at the end of the third financial
quarter of 2020 by which time the
companies had unlocked more liquid
assets and passed the initial shock
phase of the shutdown
norwegian cruise line holdings the third
largest cruise conglomerate in the world
had some 2.4 billion dollars in the bank
meanwhile the royal caribbean group had
about three billion dollars in cash
while the carnival corporation by far
the largest cruise company in the world
held about 8.2 billion dollars in cash
that's what's referred to as their
runway and the task was to get their
burn rate
how much they spend per day to stay in
existence to its lowest
possible level in the case of carnival
if they spent
50 million dollars per day for example
they would only survive some 164 days
without revenue
if they were able to get that down to
only 25 million dollars a day though
they'd have 328 days almost a year
of runway once the long-term nature of
the shutdown became clear
furloughing or firing almost all on-ship
staff and a sizeable chunk of onshore
staff
was an easy decision for cruise ship
management
one of the tougher decisions was what to
do with their key
assets the ships unlike people they
couldn't just let them go
in the case of carnival their oldest
smallest and cheapest ship
the ecstasy cost some 275
million dollars to build back in 1991.
nowadays they're building 780 million
dollar ships like the carnival panorama
put altogether this means a cruise
line's fleet
is incredibly valuable and since the
ships weren't carrying passengers around
the world
they had to put them somewhere however
as it turns out both the world's cruise
ports
and the world's cruise ships weren't
built with a total
industry shutdown in mind first of all
you can't just turn off a cruise ship
tie it up and lock the door behind you
with a very little exception from the
moment a ship enters service to the
moment
it's decommissioned there are people on
board as these massive machines require
constant monitoring and maintenance to
stay in working order
in addition cruise ports were built to
suit the need and since the early days
of the industry
the need has been for ships to stop
every week or so to unload passengers
restock and load back up they're
designed for the majority of ships to be
at sea
which historically was fine because the
majority of ships
were always at sea now however that
means there just
isn't enough space in the world's cruise
ports for every cruise ship to tie up
and wait things out in fact there's not
even close to enough space
and most ports charge ships tens of
thousands of dollars per day
to tie up so the vast majority of the
world's cruise fleet
is out at sea floating around they each
now carry an average of about 100 crew
members
a fraction of their normal staffing
levels performing the most
essential functions navigation
maintenance engineering food preparation
medical care
and more in the case of carnival 15 of
their 23 ships are currently anchored
off the coast of the bahamas
and about once a week one of them will
sail to miami to pick up food
mail and other supplies which they then
transfer between the ships upon return
most lines are operating with some
version of this floating cluster
approach
as it's clearly one of the lowest cost
methods for storage
that keeps ships in an adequate state of
readiness for when cruising
finally returns and that's the key
question
right now when will it be possible for
cruising
to return in summer 2020
some thought the answer was then
particularly in europe which had a
robust summer travel season
quite a few smaller cruise ships and
even some larger ones
brought passengers back on board with
precautions
in general this meant the ships were
capacity capped and passengers had to be
tested before boarding
were subject to temperature checks were
required to wear a mask in communal
areas
and could only go ashore on managed
excursions
with these and other rules cruise
companies thought they might have
cracked the code of sailing safely and
profitably during a pandemic
but then reality hit
on the ms rolled amundsen an expedition
cruise ship that typically carries 500
or so passengers through the arctic or
antarctic
62 people tested positive for kovid
after a trip around svalbard
putting stress on the contact tracing
system of northern
norway elsewhere in norway the sea dream
one had to cancel a cruise after a
positive covet test
and then a few months later the very
same ship left barbados on the very
first cruise in the caribbean
since the start of the pandemic which
soon had to be cancelled
due to nine passengers and crew testing
positive
on the other side of the continent
uncruised adventures left
juno in early august on the very first
cruise with passengers from an american
port since march 2020
until a passenger's test came back
positive forcing them to return to port
put all passengers under quarantine and
cancel the rest of the season
this is the reality of cruising during a
pandemic
as long as passengers are originating
from a place with rampant community
spread
no matter how many precautions are taken
it doesn't work from a public health
perspective
it doesn't work from a business
perspective it just simply
doesn't work therefore for the most part
even in the cases where governments
weren't stopping them cruise lines
stopped trying nowadays however
in spring 2021 tens of millions of
coveted vaccines are entering people's
arms
every day around the world and a
solution
has arisen instead of trying to prevent
kovid from spreading on their ships
the cruise lines are simply going to
prevent people who could have kovit
from getting on their ships many of the
major players
including royal caribbean are requiring
all adult passengers to be fully
vaccinated before boarding
even though no vaccine is 100 effective
having a fully vaccinated ship means
that even if someone does board with
kovid
this will not set off a chain reaction
of community spread throughout the
entire vessel
given these new policies cruise lines
are reworking their schedules
to center their business on the places
where vaccines are rolling out
the fastest for example with less than
two months notice
royal caribbean announced that it would
be sailing from israel home of the
world's fastest vaccination campaign
for the first time ever with one of the
largest cruise ships in the world
the odyssey of the seas in addition
while the summer crew season is
traditionally centered on the
mediterranean
in 2021 many of the first cruises to
restart
will be based out of the caribbean in
close proximity to the us
which has also had one of the world's
fastest vaccination campaigns cruise
lines have
for the most part succeeded with their
grand
challenge at the end of 2020 royal
caribbean for example
still had 3.6 billion dollars in the
bank
as runway and it pushed their burn rate
down to 270 million dollars a month
that means they can survive without
revenue until at least
february 9 2022 norwegian cruise line
meanwhile
had enough to make it until april 25th
while carnival had enough to last till
june 9th
2022 the cruise lines will be fine
but there is another side to the
equation
while cruise lines are typically massive
global enterprises
they rely on the places they visit they
rely on
all these small businesses that operate
tours and excursions for passengers at
each port of call
specifically they rely on places like
ketchikan
alaska last summer under strict coveted
protocols
i traveled there with a film crew to
document a summer like no
other a summer where the 1.2 million
annual cruise tourists that keep the
economy of this small town of 8 000
alive
just didn't show up two summers ago
ketchikan was one of the most
sought-after cruise destinations in the
world they would quite literally
run out of space on the docks last
summer
they were experiencing the most acute
form of economic
ruin the documentary i made profiling
this
is out now exclusively on nebula
it's the first on location project we've
released in almost
a year and i think you'll find it quite
interesting
of course as any long time wendover
viewer knows
the best and cheapest way to get access
to nebula
is with the curiosity stream nebula
bundle deal available
on sale for 15 a year right now
at curiositystream.com wendover
this gets you access to both nebula and
curiosity stream
where you can watch thousands of great
non-fiction shows and documentaries
like china's last little train which
profiles the last working narrow gauge
steam railway in china
connecting an area without cars buses or
even roads to the outside world
of course these subscriptions are what
goes to fund the great nebula originals
that many of you have come to enjoy
and they help independent creators like
us stay independent
so get a year's worth of education and
entertainment
with access to both curiosity stream and
nebula where you can watch our brand new
documentary
for just 15 a year with the current sale
at curiositystream.com
wendover